when we last saw dexter morgan he had
abandoned his young son faked his death
and become
well a lumberjack complete with a big
beard and his own small trailer in the
middle of oregon
the new revival of the popular dexter
series on showtime set
eight years after the finale will see
the well-meaning titular serial killer
played by michael c
hall living under an assumed identity in
iron lake new york
he will be dealing with new setbacks and
foes including the villainous mayor
caldwell
played by clancy brown and chief of
police angela bishop
played by julia jones as executive
producer clyde phillips warned viewers
heads will roll
this is dexter people are going to die
when john lithgow was added to the
revival however
fans were understandably curious about
what his actual role would be
his character arthur mitchell aka the
trinity killer was killed by dexter at
the end of season 4.
how exactly does someone come back from
that especially with dexter's patented
methods
that assure his victims are truly gone
john lithgow won an emmy for his
frightening work as mitchell and was
arguably a pivotal character on the show
he was a foil for dexter who could
seemingly balance his double life as a
serial killer with his role as a husband
and father
in some ways dexter finally found
someone he could relate to as a person
at least when it came to his most primal
desires and the justifications of his
actions
by killing dexter's wife rita however
the trinity killer a man who was abusive
toward his own family
put an end to dexter's dream of having
it all as both a killer
and a family man dexter kills mitchell
and the trinity killer persona along
with him
though his inner peace is still years
away we can speculate about how arthur
will return to the show but according to
deadline
lithgow is only working for about a day
on set
if this is the case it's unlikely that
his character will be a consistent
presence during the revival
we also don't expect him to portray
someone other than mitchell
as the trinity killer is still one of
the most unsettling characters in all of
tv
there must be a specific reason that
lithgow has rejoined the show
and for this we need to look deeply into
the personality of dexter
how long could dexter suppress his
natural urges that should be one of the
biggest questions you ask when the new
episodes air
away from the constant threat and
temptation that a normal life brought
him
dexter's new weapon of choice is an axe
but instead of cutting into human flesh
he's cutting into trees
it can't possibly be what he really
wants could it somewhere inside an inner
voice pokes at him reminding him of his
true nature
hello dexter morgan
while dexter may have decided toward the
end of his run as a killer that he no
longer needs to code
that doesn't mean his demons have left
the trinity killer took dexter's wife
away cutting deeper than any blade
it's not much of a stretch to think that
the dark passenger could return
but this time what if it bears a new
face a simple reminder of who dexter is
and what he's capable of wouldn't take
much dialogue
lithgow probably didn't need any more
than a day on set to deliver an
emotionally compelling exchange with
dexter
their scene or scenes could be the
catalyst that causes dexter to return to
his murderous life or it might be a
final catharsis for the former forensics
master
although the trinity killer is back that
doesn't mean dexter will snap and murder
the first person who he thinks deserves
it let's be honest though what is dexter
without a high body count
viewers aren't going to return for the
reformed killer who has conquered his
emotional and mental instabilities
closure for the audience may not be the
same as clojure for dexter
and you won't be surprised if arthur
mitchell is a spark that lights a new
fire
in dexter's soul we'll find out exactly
how arthur mitchell will return to
dexter when the revival premieres in the
fall of 2021
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
showtime's dexter revival are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one